- YO, AMERICA.
WHAT IT IS.
IT'S JAH-BOY
ADAM "SO FINE" DEVINE,
AND I'M HERE TO WEL-CON-UM YOU
TO HOUSE PAR--
AAH!
I HATE IT.
IT'S STUPID.
CUT.
- CUT?
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
- OKAY, WHAT AM I TALKING ABOUT?
YOU'RE SITTING OVER THERE
THROWING OUT BAD VIBES TO ME
WHEN I'M GIVING MY ALL
TO THIS SHOW.
I NEED A DIRECTOR
WHO'S MORE DYNAMIC,
WHO THROWS MORE "SNAPABILITY"
INTO THE SITUATION.
- "SNAPABILITY" IS NOT A WORD,
ADAM.
- HOW ARE YOU SUPPOSED TO BE
A DIRECTOR
WHO DOESN'T EVEN KNOW
DIRECTING WORDS...
- OH, JESUS CHRIST.
- LIKE "SNAPABILITY"?
OKAY, IF I WERE TO DIRECT
THESE EPISODES,
THEY'D PROBABLY MOST LIKELY
BE THE BEST ONES EVER,
BECAUSE I HAVE
A CREATIVE SPARK
BURNING IN MY HEAD
AND MY HEART AREA,
UNLIKE SOMEONE I KNOW,
WHICH IS WHO YOU ARE.
- ALL RIGHT, ADAM.
THEN YOU DIRECT THE SHOW.
YOU DIRECT THE SHOW, MAN.
- FINE, I WILL.
- HERE'S YOUR DUMBASS
LITTLE SCRIPT ON THE GROUND.
- OKAY, THAT'S NOT A--I ACTUALLY
WORKED KIND OF HARD ON THAT.
- SHUT UP, DUDE. I'M OUT.
- YOU SHUT UP.
I'M GOING TO THE BAYOU.
I'M GONNA WRESTLE GATORS
AND SHIT.
HAVE FUN.
- I WILL HAVE FUN.
- BYE, MIKEY.
SEE YOU, GOONERS.
- AH, COOL.
'SUP, DUDE?
YEAH, ALL RIGHT.
WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
WHAT DO YOU DO?
OH!
[theme music plays]